there are lots of places dotted around
North Kensington within shouting
distance of Grenville tower where
community spirit comes in the shape of
bags of food clothing nappies bedding
and pretty much anything else the
survivors of the deadly fire might need
as they begin their lives anew with
nothing
pastor Derek Wilson that the Tabernacle
Church is staggered by the response in
the worst of times the best of human
nature well this is overwhelming to see
the response of ordinary people just
coming to see what they can do offering
the help offering donate stuff it's
amazing it's amazing and I'm really
taken aback by this the only thing in
short supply here is floor space the
generosity of people both local and not
boundless and finding places to accept
donations soon becomes a significant
issue ed Davis and Andrew ER knew our
removal men but for now all they're
moving is donated supplies for the
Grenville tower disaster to wherever
they're needed the main thing is to get
out ready we got we've got food and
stuff only that's what we really want to
get off we hitched a ride as they made
another drop to one of the many
reception centers we're not all the
drops are successful we just arrived at
one of the centers which apparently does
have some space but even they don't want
to take it because it's now all got to
be coordinated from a central point so
we've got to go there many of the
center's just can't take any more
donations but it didn't seem to stop
people trying so great was the need to
help I was sitting at home watching
people launching themselves off a tall
building and this very nifty video got
me
maybe get on these gates got
inside your cupboard go to the shop buy
a few things it's nothing is it really
even if they lost everything they're
still people around here that wants to
help could have been me
could have been any of us but I think
it's you know my sense was were
Londoners we help one another out and
reluctantly the volunteers here too had
to turn gifts away but when your home is
burned down you need more than a food
drink toiletries and clothes you need
somewhere to lay your head and there
have been offers of help with that to
the unfortunate truth of this tragedy is
that donations turned away now may well
be needed for tomorrow and the next day
and the next the generosity of this
community will need to end or for some
time yet Dave Aude and Sky News in West
London